[Music]
super teams are as exciting as they are
volatile when you put some of the game's
greatest players together on one team
they should be dominant but sometimes
that's not how things work out
once we've got Nico I knew that at some
point we need to change up the new two
players not to bless but Q and L oh
there was something missing to be the
best we we were in four or five finals
with with that lineup in that period but
the socially and the clicking didn't
really fit in game now that Kerrigan has
announced that he's been benched from
faze clan it's a pretty good time to
look back at how the roster started and
how they didn't let their first failure
define them
[Music]
faze clan added both Guardian and
olofmeister in August 2017 joining Nikko
Carrigan and rain on a stacked roster
but fans wondered how would all these
big names on one lineup actually work
out the amount of things that have to
work out for a super team to work
it's really quite staggering if you try
and sort of put it all together in your
mind most of the players yet they have
sort of certain frameworks that they
like to play within so if you find five
players that will play within the exact
same framework then probably you're
you're missing you know somebody else in
the tactics or even on the map you know
like what if they don't like playing
that position and what they all like
playing the same position just to put it
sort of in the most simple terms they
wouldn't have to wait very long phase
played their first match is just two
weeks after forming at Dreamhack masters
Malmo but things didn't go so well
they found themselves in Group C
arguably the easiest group in the
tournament and on paper they should have
made it out before the terminus started
we didn't have that much practice and I
think one of the mistakes I did I think
in leader was believing that the new
lineup would fit into the mapper we had
first faith played against ninjas in
pyjamas team that hadn't seen any
serious wins in a long time but nip took
out face 16 to 8 on nuke sage has been
really good on the nuke before that for
me and Guardian never played nuke with
me
Guardian a single bullet away from death
and it's gonna be almost that the hands
of Drake and it seemed he was looking
the wrong way they did manage to beat
Mountain Sports on Mirage but then they
wants to gambit two-to-one in their
decider match I think we knew we threw
it away especially in the last game I
get gambit faceless out of the
tournament losing to teams that they
probably should have beaten even though
some of the members were pretty new the
memo he checked was a failure and for a
new team filled with some of the biggest
names in the game that could have been a
problem but instead of kicking back and
enjoying the hotel minibar for the
weekend the players were to work so we
went back and look at the mistakes and
quickly we realized that that nuke
doesn't fit us right now so we cut that
from the metal the greatest way to learn
something is to
do it I mean we did our mistakes but we
we have to learn from it and we have to
like understand what we did wrong the
team went back to the practice room at
an event they were eliminated from and
tried to work things out
those first time I've been a face where
actually they all stay together and try
to improve and I think that that showed
the will to win in this team Kerrigan
took stock of the team's preferences and
decided to try out a new map war one
that didn't include nuke and not only
did the team come together they started
to get results that was a honeymoon
period everybody wanted to do everything
well Malmo was disappointing days went
on an absolute tear afterwards they won
ESL one New York and the 2017 csgo elite
premier defeating team liquid and a
straw Louis to do so that there were two
players there four straws the flashes if
it's good olofmeister takes down two
free now they know where the remaining
players are coming from it's inevitable
it is over 67 whey-faced have done it
they are you're a league champions and
after a string of mostly second and
third place finishes
they won the ECS season for finals but
despite having some really good momentum
going into it phase took a heartbreaking
second place finish at the Boston major
Guardian waits patiently as cloud
myselfi push up
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
major champions Guardian has said that
phase will be his last roster and that
no roster sticks together forever I'm
already married soon some baby will come
so I don't want to be the kind of play
that is turning a lot and then I'm
missing most the most important years of
my child so I think faze clan will be my
last home as a active player but as
other teams like cloud9 who beat phase
in the boss a major collapsed phase has
stayed mostly intact phase overcame
their losses at Malmo and Boston and the
resilience was key to remaining one of
the game's top teams even though a major
win proved elusive hitting the practice
room instead of sightseeing gave them
the start they needed to succeed super
teams by definition have talent but
phase at Malmo showed us what it takes
to turn that talent into a cohesive unit
with Kerrigan now on the sidelines a new
phase will likely face problems of their
own but showing professionalism and
being willing to fix problems early just
like they did at Malmo could be the key
to future success
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button